welcome to the David Pakman show I'm
fairing cousins from Ring of Fire
sitting in for David today David has a
speaking engagement and hopefully that
clip will be available on youtube.com
slash mid-week politics sometime in the
very near future
so let's get started today obviously
Donald Trump is out there in Twitter
world as he is every single day except
today a little bit more ominous message
showing that maybe he really doesn't
care about his responsibilities as the
president of the United States first and
foremost one of the big Donald Trump was
tweeting about this morning was the fact
that he's ready to pull out of Puerto
Rico may we have American citizens on an
island a United States territory these
people are United States citizens and
Donald Trump is out there telling them
look hey we're not gonna stay there
forever we've got to move on we've got
other things to do so you know best of
luck to you unfortunately he didn't even
tell them best of luck here's the tweets
Donald Trump sent out this morning about
what he's telling Puerto Rico today
Puerto Rico survived the hurricanes now
a financial crisis looms largely of
their own making says cheryl atkinson
that was a quote and now a total lack of
accountability says the governor
electric and all infrastructure was
disaster before hurricanes Congress to
decide how much to spend we cannot keep
FEMA the military and the first
responders who have been amazing under
the most difficult circumstances in
Puerto Rico forever
again and I cannot say this enough these
people who are suffering where you have
a millions down there you know most of
them do not have clean water to drink in
fact reports have come out today showing
that the EPA is actually having to issue
warnings to people to stop drinking the
water out of Superfund sites those
highly polluted toxic areas people are
so desperate for water that they have
been going down to these Superfund sites
and
to grab it by the bucketful and take it
back home because they have nothing and
Donald Trump today has the audacity to
say look your country was in shambles
before these storms so don't expect us
to stay down there forever you've got a
huge financial crisis that that you
created which is not the truth and so
we're gonna have to pull out eventually
Congress is going to decide how much to
spend how much your lives are worth
basically let's put it in its simplest
terms there because that's what he's
talking about when he says Congress is
gonna decide how much to spend he's
really saying Congress is going to sit
here and decide how much money your
lives are worth and again that is just
one of the many things that Donald Trump
was talking about today but I mean at
least maybe at least he's paying
attention to Puerto Rico if only to
insult and tell them that they're not
gonna have much help from the federal
government meanwhile the state of
California a hundred and seventy
thousand acres are on fire twenty three
people so far that we know of have been
killed by these fires hundreds of
structures all across the state burnt to
the ground and so far Mike Pence has
been on Twitter saying oh we're with you
were sending first responders Donald
Trump has been eerily silent
about these wildfires raging throughout
the state of California again 170
thousand acres of mainland United States
up in flames 23 people as of right now
dead because of this and not a word from
our president instead again he's
tweeting out threats to Puerto Rico he's
tweeting out nonsense about the media
being unfair to him you know
yesterday and for the week and a half
prior to that he's tweeting about the
NFL he's tweeting about
Jerry Jones the owner of the Dallas
Cowboys saying he's so proud of him for
for forcing his players to stand during
the national anthem he's talking about
how disrespectful and dishonorable it is
for these NFL players to be kneeling
he's going after a ESPN host Jamel Hill
for taking the side of these players who
are protesting racism instead of
focusing on the real issues I mean look
we already know yeah he tweeted about
Puerto Rico this morning but when he
went down there to survey the damage he
wasn't walking around in the areas that
were hardest hit he wasn't looking at
those people who are taking buckets down
to Superfund sites so that they can fill
them up to have water to give to their
families he was in an auditorium
throwing paper towels at people as if
he's shooting t-shirts out of a cannon
at a baseball game that's not leadership
that's not what those people needed I'm
sure they probably did at some point
need paper towels but on the list of
priorities of things for the island
things that people need paper towels
probably not going to be too high on
that list what they need is electricity
what they need is clean water they need
food they need medical assistance and
all Donald Trump did was go down to the
island throw a couple of paper towels on
people fly back to the United States and
immediately go right back to distracting
the American public so they don't pay
attention to what's actually happening
in this country and that's the bottom
line with all of this that's the point
the reason Donald Trump goes out there
and he picks fights on Twitter with the
NFL is cuz he doesn't want us to focus
on the real issues he doesn't want us to
understand what's actually happening in
this country today I know they talk a
big game about tax reform but they don't
want us to actually look at what's
inside it they don't want the media to
spend all of their time reporting on the
tax package or reporting on this
executive order on Obamacare so he goes
out there he does what he does best he
distracts us he distracts
Media so that they focus on a couple of
stupid tweets instead of the fact that
California is burning and people are
dying instead of focusing on the fact
that people in Puerto Rico are dying and
the death toll down there is estimated
to be far higher than anything the
government has reported yet but again
the media has this obsession
if Trump tweets about something that's
the issue of the day the NFL thing is
the perfect example of it we've been
talking about this now for over a week
and a half and it's because Trump is
trying to keep it alive why because we
don't want to or he doesn't want us to
see his horrible response to Puerto Rico
he doesn't want us to see his horrible
response to the wildfires in California
he doesn't want us to see the horrible
response and the lack of action for the
massacre that took place in Las Vegas
recently and that's another another part
of the issue instead of talking about
gun control instead of doing something
about it instead of having spirited
debates in the halls of Congress they're
trying to outlaw abortion this week not
too many reports on that why because
Donald Trump tweets out stupid things
and they get distracted from it yeah it
generates web traffic it generates
viewers on TV but it does nothing to
keep the American public informed about
what's actually happening in this
country and that's what is so vital
today and that's what is missing largely
from a lot of the conversations that
have happened in the corporate media
regarding what Donald Trump is or isn't
doing he is ignoring California he is
ignoring the issue of gun control in the
massacre in Las Vegas yes he visited
there he went to the hospital found a
trump supporter willing to stand up with
a bullet in him to shake hands with the
president it made for a great photo op
but it did absolutely nothing to provide
comfort for the victims over there in
Las Vegas I had a friend of mine who was
at that concert when the shots rang out
she's a
event promoter she was actually on a day
off there in Vegas happened to be at
that concert she was so excited been
posting about it on social media all day
and she she's told the story of how the
shots rang out and everybody took off
running and then as more shots everybody
drops people are diving into cars you
know she still is talking about the fact
that she still can't get over it and I
know she's not alone most of these
people need some kind of help they need
a helping hand they need more than a
photo-op
they they need you know therapy sessions
to work through what happened to work
through the fact that they were sitting
there with their friends or their family
or people they just met there or
complete strangers and they watched them
get mowed down by a madman in a hotel
across the street it's almost impossible
for somebody to really be able to
process that and that's why they need
help they don't need photo ops of of the
president in the hospital they need a
leader to come out and say we're gonna
we're gonna help you we're gonna get you
what you need we're gonna set up you
know a therapy for you guys so you can
work through this so you don't go the
rest of your life with PTSD because you
weren't able to process it because
nobody was there to lend a helping hand
Donald Trump is not the leader that we
need in this country not by any means
and he's proven that time and time again
it happened up with with a the hurricane
so happened with Harvey happen with Irma
happen with Maria happen with the
wildfires happened with the shooting and
this is just all in the last month and a
half two months folks I don't know what
other examples we need to come up with
in order for everyone to understand the
Donald Trump clearly does not want to be
President of the United States it's as
simple as that his response to these
disasters to the things that actually
needed his attention has been beyond
appalling and rather than addressed them
rather than send the resources necessary
he's out there picking
fights with Republican Congress members
picking fights with the media picking
fights with the NFL and this is all a
distraction
Donald Trump has become the distracter
in chief and with the corporate media it
works it's been a great tactic so as
much as he complains about fake news
they are feeding right in to his tactic
here to get them to avoid talking about
what's actually happening in this
country to get them to not focus on the
fact that his disaster response one of
the main things we need him to do as
president has been worse than abysmal
and that's what we're dealing with today
we have to understand that again Donald
Trump clearly doesn't want to be
President he wants the glitz and the
glamour and the power and the title but
he doesn't want any of the
responsibility that comes along with
holding that position I'm fair and
cousin sitting in for David Pakman today
you're listening to the David Pakman
show we'll be right back